hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry we're
gonna check out the trailer for mr. and
mrs. Smith part two back their bag it's
a movie called by the sea I hear it's a
romantic drama oh just as fun three our
first strong sexuality nice nudity nice
so it's gonna be like a mr. Moses
elegant sext I hope so because it could
be like the mr. mr. Smith scenes but
with actual nudity now and language
maybe they talk dirty to each other I
guess he brad pitt and Jolie [ __ ]
bomb no it's just that she speaks Korean
well she doesn't he speak Swahili
actually take that out
I'm afraid a relationship problem
it's kind of like don't this kind of
looks like if we should leave later
trying to make us 60s
you know my reason you're nothing yeah
which he took his last name that's what
I got from that trailer watch that again
yeah I might just look at it again real
fast
I get a revolutionary robot
you know like account having everything
but it makes it look like new where yeah
to in its shot beautifully a little bit
of like a soft warm
you know my reason
what I like about it is it has a
thriller element to it you know and well
yeah an each piece of this trailer kind
of seems like it communicates three
different tones of the movie I I like
that yeah you know you got like the
slow-moving drama you got this artistic
miss about it and then you also have
feels very naturalistic Eckerd there
there's the romantic aspect and then
there's this thriller aspect you know so
you got drama romance thriller you got
all three genres really being present
here Angelina Jolie and Brad Pitt coming
together ah coming together happens that
that happens I mean she probably likes
cream pies no I should probably with
that attachme has kids right I think
it's just for porn like other people
actually do that like frequently that
could be really wrong no you can be very
wrong trust me I don't know it kind of
has like an old-school like it kind of
feels like a Michael Douglas movie
yeah I might good disclosure fatal
attraction days and [ __ ] Basic
Instinct like I don't know why but I get
that sort of vibe of it yeah well
especially the first part like it feels
like a 60s or maybe like in early 70s
movie you know like it yeah just shot
kind of like that and it has that sort
of naturalistic like you're in a place
feels like those movies had yeah if you
feel like it's gonna be like a
slow-moving tension thriller yeah
hopefully it's an erotic thriller
I mean it's rated R for strong sexual
content and nudity so if we don't see
Brad Pitt's ding-a-ling-a-ling going I'm
gonna be very upset oh I know but it's
better if it's like shot would like film
you know more day not coming or not from
a paparazzi guy up in the trees catching
yeah backyard I've seen the photos well
living for more dynamic coloring yeah
and we've already seen Angelina Jolie's
tits and several films she's got a great
ass too
time for a bad shot lady if Brad Pitt
and Angelina Jolie you're coming
together for by the sea they better show
us some full frontal nudity that's what
I'm asking for anyway guys if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real
rejects you can check out reason see
gariand ain't gas stoves on this channel
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine and periscope because if we
get more followers we can get even more
product placement we're only about the
money you see when you make that joke
people will go I knew it you guys any
about the money
every youtuber who has you know rather
successful youtuber they only do it for
the money
sorry to tell you guys we all do it just
for the money it's only about money
money is what makes everything run
better no the kids yeah why did your
honesty but I don't want the woman to do
more things with you yet pay her more
money money power what scarface is
number one rule in the process of
getting the woman the sitter so Angela
Jolie and Brad Pitt let's see some full
frontal I do what you like me full
frontal or I'll sort of rebuttal that's
worse